[Music]
elise
yeah
yeah
i'm just thinking about how on bim came
for auntie
i mean she said everything that my mom
would have wanted her to say and
everything that i've been wanted to say
ugh it just feels good to know that
people have your back
all right
mind if i uh get in with you
thank you
for stepping in for carlton today
i really don't know what i would have
done without you
you know
you know it was his idea
really
yeah
he knows how much this event meant to
you
we're just going to leave you hunting
hey
i miss this
just like
vibing
hanging with you
me too
so is there a reason that you've been so
distant lately
i don't want to be another person in
your life that you have to navigate
around
you know
lisa
i think you are
the most amazing girl
i've ever known
i mean that
but
i don't want to bring any more drama in
your life so if that means i gotta back
off give you enough space you know what
i mean
i'll do that
even if it hurts
is that what you
want i don't know
no
but
me neither
[Music]
me
[Music]
pushing me